das hier sind die letzten Sekunden
zweier kunstflug-piloten bei Gera zwei
Maschinen beim Training eine
atemberaubende Show schon hunderte Male
vorgeführt doch dieses Mal geht etwas
schief die beiden Piloten krachen in der
Luft zusammen sie verhaken sich und
stürzen ab die Flugzeuge gehen sofort in
Flammen auf die beiden Männer können
sich leider nicht retten und es hätte
alles hier sehen wir den Zusammenstoß
hier sehen wir wie sich die Tragflächen
ineinander verhaken wie keine Chance
mehr bestand für die beiden Piloten und
es hätte tatsächlich sie sehen es im
Vordergrund die Häuser es hätte noch
viel viel schlimmer kommen können
[Musik]
dieses Video zeigt die dramatischen
Sekunden vor dem tödlichen
Flugzeugunglück im thüringischen Gera
bei diesem Manöver kommt es zu der
Tragödie die beiden Flugzeuge kommen
sich zu nahe die Maschinen verhaken sich
Stürzen zu Boden explodieren nach dem
Aufprall beide Piloten ein 73-jähriger
und ein 42-jähriger sterben bei dem
Unglück wir haben mittlerweile
Zeugenaussagen und Videodokumentationen
bekommen wo wir sehen können dass zwei
Luftfahrzeuge sich in der Luft berührt
haben sich wie wir sehen können auch
verkeilt haben und in dem Zustand auch
zu Boden gekommen sind es handelt sich
um ein motorige Maschinen tschechischer
Bauart die Flugzeuge waren schon 50
Jahre alt die Piloten sollen zur
Kunstflugstaffel Gera gehören die
Flugzeuge verfügen in denen
Gewichtsklassen über keine
Flugdatenschreiber keine Cockpit Voice
Recorder Aufzeichnung es gibt keine
Flugweg Aufzeichnung generell ein Drama
dass sich vor den Augen liebe Zuschauer
abspielt doch es hätte noch viel
schlimmer kommen können nur 150 Meter
von der Absturzstelle entfernt stehen
Wohnhäuser es hätte auch eine
Katastrophe mit vielen Toten geben
können
die beiden Piloten wollten über den
Köpfen der Zuschauer ein akrobatisches
Manöver fliegen einen sogenannten
spiegelflug es ist erstmal noch nicht
geklärt wie trainiert auch die
pilotenwaren in diesem Manöver wie oft
sie das vollzogen haben da stehen wir
noch am Anfang der Ermittlung wir gehen
erstmal nicht von einem technischen
Defekt grundlegend aus ist aber nicht
auszuschließen
die Anwohner unter Schock nicht
auszudenken was passiert wäre wären die
Maschinen über ihren Häusern abgestürzt
[Musik]